hey leute bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum
ende des videos dran weil ihr könnt in
diesem video und endo 3ds xl gewinnen
und ich sage am ende wer von euch letzte
woche die playstation 4 gewonnen hat
also jetzt viel spaß
hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video und möchte euch heute 19 dinge
vorstellen die jeder tut allerdings ist
gegen die nicht so ganz zuge
beziehungsweise gar nicht vor augen hat
dass er es tut bevor ich euch allerdings
diese neuen wege zeigen muss ich doch
etwas zu einem hammer in meinem video
vor einer woche habe ich diese
playstation 4 an jemanden von euch
verlost der einheitssatz abonnent von
meinem canales und andererseits irgend
ein kommentar darüber geschrieben hat
wie ich ihn erreichen kann und in dem
video habe ich ja außerdem gesagt dass
ab diesem letzten samstag jedem neuen
samstag bis einschließlich heiligabend
ich etwas neues verlosen werden das
heißt in diesem video hier verlor sich
eine neue sogar sehe ich gerade also
steht in hugh grant ich denke damit
nicht so ganz aus aber ich glaube heißt
nur wenn ihr also diese nintendo 3ds xl
nach hause zugesandte von mir bekommen
habt euch was ist das für ein deutsch
einfach nur zwei sachen warten und zwar
erstens meinen kanal abonnieren
enttäuscht ist und zweitens einfach
einen kommentar unter dieses video wir
schreiben nicht erreichen kann also
beispielsweise auf instagram kaputt sie
auf twitter palmen liebhaberin ihr könnt
also viele kommentare schreiben wie ihr
wollt also wirst du merken unterschreibt
desto öfter nimmt ihr quasi am
gewinnspiel teil weil ich das ganze mit
einer website alles raus suche und es
war sie das ganze hier so aus also das
ist das video dieser website geht gerade
die ganzen kommentare durch den ist
gerade bei kommentar 36.000 und reden
wir dann endlich irgendeinem fremden
kommentar aussuchen so dass das ganze
auch legitime mit rechten dingen zugeht
es wollte ich würde sagen wenn ihr euch
dafür interessiert die playstation
letztes mal gewonnen habt hier ich
irgendwann im video ist ja heute fertigt
wir den ganzen kommentaren aussuchen das
heißt in einem video werden welcher
fahrer gewinner ist aber jetzt erstmal
zu den 19 gegen die ich euch vorstellen
wollte min son ist in der way you are
you can zurück ist am panel das ist ohne
spaß so ich habe das immer wenn ich
ihnen supermarkt gehe ich suche
irgendwie die milch und entschied
dagegen generell vor der mädchen dadurch
so daneben soll der schirm brötchen hier
eigentlich erwarte einfach bissiger
elfmeters oder die starring die nex
customer unit finish putting a change in
the wall ist auch so typische supermacht
beispiel bzw
zum beispiel beim bäcker und zwar wenn
du einfach an der kasse bezahlt und dies
haben schon alle produkte durch
gescannte bis auf einem einpacken die
wechselte schon das rückgeld wurde auf
einmal kommen der nächste über einer
kasse und die sachen von dem werde ich
schon gesteht um kicken sofort eine
karte sachen weg und du musst nicht so
richtig bei der das ist stress pur bei
facebook mit pasta und norbert nadina
für youtube de hallo ich hatte damals
eine übelste opfer situation nicht
anhalten
einer straßenseite von der ampel war
halt ein kollege von mir bis ich aus der
schule kannte und ich bin immer die
straße gegangen und somit noch einer
befahrenen straße in bielefeld und
jedenfalls nichts rüber gelaufen ich so
high und isst er läuft einfach jeder
autofahrer blogger ausgedacht das hat
weil ich zu wenig sagen wie sie mit dem
ihr zu tun aber das wird sich nun mal
loswerden weil ich bin opfer junge ist
diese website
die ganzen kommentaren durch 150000
kommentare unter dem video auf 1500
seiten und er ist gerade bei 50.000
amazing wir warten wahrscheinlich noch
bis morgen zwischen gewinnspiel
teilnehmen
mit james listen to the strangers
conversations im menschlichen jordanien
ich mache das einfach immer immer wenn
ich irgendwie in der stadt bildern leute
vorbei laufe in der bahn auf steige da
wieder an leuten einer rolltreppe
vorbeilaufen oder so immer ich achte
immer darauf über was die anderen reden
weil das richtiges deutsch das ist ein
enorm schlimm wenn ich mit meinem kumpel
viel unterwegs bin so gelaufen so
zusammen rum laufen somit ist an uns
vorbei oder halten sich so und man hört
ja immer so ein zwei sätze aus der
unterhaltung oder läuft sein an denen
vorbei und eine höher seiten oder diese
aufgeschnappten sätze von wegen ja und
wenn die mutter macht das überhaupt
nicht und wir führen ihr unterhalten
werden wir sofort die macht das echt gar
nicht wenn du dein zimmer nicht aufräumt
bleiben hier dies das müsst ihr einfach
mal machen das macht so spart ihr lauft
einfach an leuten vorbei und dann wenn
sie irgendwas sagen könnt ihr so die
kommunikation so ein bisschen vor wie
heute baut wenn die batteries get low
ich mach das nicht nur wenn die
batterien schwachsinn sondern macht das
eigentlich immer wenn ich mir denken ja
oder kann ich das am besten erreichen
und ja ich mache jeden tag immer wenn
ich fernsehe komitees torwart dort bei
anything you can use and natural uhr in
essen
ich hab das immer also auf deutsch
übersetzt fahren sie denn ihren in den
shop reihen geht in irgendeinen
einkaufscenter im supermarkt keine
ahnung was ihr schaut euch um und findet
nichts umgeht dann wieder raus an der
kasse vorbei dass ihr euch einfach so
total natürlich verhalten wenn ihr
wirklich nichts falsch gemacht hätte
ohne spaß schreibt mir mal bitte in die
kommentare wie viele sachen hiervon auf
euch zu treffen weil ich habe jetzt alle
rausgesucht über seine snap chat story
bald noch viel mehr sachen vorgestellt
wurden und die sachen treffen alle auf
mich zu meiner gäste blockten aus der
folie entwickelt ein neues wort und
blaffte verrentet ich bis jetzt war gar
nicht so krass auf dieses blockierte
nase
erkältet schnupfen ding sondern bei mir
war es halt einfach so ich habe mir zwei
mal hintereinander mein handgelenk
gebrochen einmal beim fahrradfahren
gezählt beim bmx fahren und einmal
weinen war dass ich noch beim fußball
oder so das ist weil es innerhalb von
fünf monaten passiert ich musste immer
nach seinen tipps tragen und im verband
und haft erhalten monat immer mit einem
müllsack wie duschen konnten wir nur mit
links die zähne putzen und alles und
dann schätzt man erst wie es ist wenn
man das nicht hat und genauso ist es
irgendwie mit einer blockiert nase sage
ich mal also erst wenn man wirklich
etwas hat schätzt man wie es ist oder
schätzt man dass es so krass gesund zu
sein zum beispiel das ja ich weiss nicht
eigentlich können wir uns die ganze zeit
bedanken dass wir gesund sind ein lied
pictures und bei frauen bei dem special
foto oder like einer ferneren das ticket
kamen handy erkennt
es ist bei mir jedes mal so ich schaue
mir die bilder an auf meinem handy und
so rauchbach 4000 fotos 3000 videos gehe
ich muss mal was löschen und
letztendlich wird man vielleicht 10 15
screenshots die man mal gemacht haben
den rest lässt man einfach drauf ich
gucke mir das zwar nie an meine ganzen
bilder aber in irgendeiner situation
irgendwann muss man dieses bild dann
vielleicht mal irgendwie zeigen oder so
deswegen lässt man sicherheitshalber oft
mehr handy drauf was mache ich hier für
positionen mit meinen händen einfach ich
die pace technik ersetzt so im
hintergrund liegt aktuell der gewinner
bekommt übrigens auch ein usb stick das
habe ich ganz vergessen zu sagen also da
ist ein persönliches video von mir drauf
damit ihr nicht einfach nur was
materialistisches bekommt sondern auch
eine persönliche botschaft also ja sagt
meinel
think you know what to do that you lose
musikmanager street adresse wetter jeden
fall
ich mache jedes mal und es macht
überhaupt keinen sinn immer ich habe
schon versucht zu erklären aber wirklich
immer wenn man in einer fremden stadt
ist du suchst wieder einen parkplatz und
hatte keine ahnung was man macht musik
leiser um sie besser und gucken zu
können ich hab mir das einfach damit
erklärt dass man nicht so abgelenkt wird
durch die musik und andererseits auch
straßengeräusche von ihm berufenen autos
oder tatsächlich besser wahrnehmen zu
können aber eigentlich macht es
überhaupt keinen sinn die opening machte
washing herbert seconds geschäftige
demon s forge ich hab das war nicht wenn
ich mir die haare ein shampoo niere oder
wenig duschen bin aber immer wenn ich
quasi ich sag mal irgendwie die zähne
putze mich danach übersprechen beuge und
heißt ausspucken ich sage mir nach oben
folge habe ich als alter bis jetzt
bestellt irgendwas im spiegel
aber hey ich weiß es heute ist total
positiv dann aber ihr könnt mir nicht
sagen auch alle unter euch die erzählt
werden und im internet die größten eier
haben die können wir nicht sagen dass es
bei euch auch so ist jetzt ihr euch
einfach irgendwann schon mal gedacht
haben jetzt viele weg kommt wieder in
den spiegel da steht einer hinter mir
auf einmal also hier liegt ein
verwendeten bei euch nieder fire and
certainly bekommt nach vorne waiting
solches training circle news nach vorne
gehen das passiert mir so fucking oft
ich liege im bett hat mein handy in der
hand
guckst du drauf ich bin aber instagram
accadis macher das sind auf einmal
willst du
einfach von irgendeinem anrufe und soll
da auf einen baum zu reden und dann
hängst du einfach nur so soll ich jetzt
gehen die auflegen drücken soll ich hier
dieses news taste drücken aber dass
richter andré heller mit das heißt nicht
einfach nur so als wenn mein handy gegen
bochum liegen würde und ich will nicht
hören
eigentlich bin ich in übelster wechseln
die african effektiv ixos von i want for
the use of sleep alles liebe ich hatte
ein praktikum gemacht von oktober
letzten jahres willst mehr als diesen
jahres und die zweite hälfte meines
praktikums habe ich halt in düsseldorf
gemacht bei ford in der marketingagentur
ich weiß habe ich das hier schon mal
gesagt habe aber ja ich habe praktikum
bei ford gemacht als ich immer die
ganzen tweets rausgehauen hat von wenig
kann ich bin und bin voll müde uns und
auch ich mich jetzt nicht auch beziehen
und zwar was dort so dass ich halt nach
düsseldorf fahren müssen düsseldorf sein
musste das heißt sie musste halt in köln
leben wie immer so um 7 uhr 36 aufstehen
und wegen meinem youtube-videos und
wegen der rückfahrt und wegen training
und allem bin ich damals erst um 2 uhr
ein gefährt ist und ich habe mir
wirklich jede nach jeden abend bevor ich
lag und geben wollte gedanken darüber
macht ok bekommt jetzt drei stunden
schlaf oder vier stunden schlaf heute
nah und ich habe dann immer noch 20
minuten abgezogen weil sie mal so 20
minuten brauchen wirklich ein zu kennen
und badespaß diese ganze zeit die man
sich darüber gedanken macht wie lang man
schlafen kann in der zeit wird man
einfach schon längst einstellen wollen
galguera voßkuhle news.de danneberg von
toni mitleid ist muss ich glaube ich
nicht zu sagen kennt jeder an fast jeder
durch ihre situation entdeckt ist eine
kuschel bist du denn also denkst könnten
nicht einfach sitzen bleiben webfähige
love you have no idea what
ihr könnt es nicht vermeiden ihr macht
das alle auch bin und irgendwann witz
satire die razzien alter audi hat das
überhaupt nicht richtig verstanden was
er gesagt hat einfach
[Musik]
niedriges ernstes juli kurz vor schluss
möchte ich schon aber die change and
economy
ja ich bin genauso ein kandidat erwartet
focke den pay to jedes mal beim
oberhofer oder schwarz nord runaways
möglich mache warum aber hey ich werde
dich die aufgemacht hat mir gesagt haben
mir diese barriere an siehst du ab und
an und dann ist also an diesem kaugummi
so noch die hälfte von papieren und
trotzdem immer gefressen
mit js klicks to make sure that the
world habe das zwar nicht oder salat
sonne aber ich hab so ein spaghetti
clipper und immer wenn ich dir wo er
benutze so immer gefreut ich spaghetti 5
ich bin instrument spieler weil die
recording auf die ohren heute mit dem
pressing julia das ist wenn wir nicht so
krass weil ich halt jeden tag in die mit
meiner stimme sagen ich mal konfrontiert
werde wenn ich bei der video schneide
oder auf mein youtube-kanal g oder so
also ich glaub ich hab ich das ein
bisschen dran gewöhnt aber enorm viele
kollegen oder freude denn von mir die
mir schon mal etwas aufgenommen haben
oder in blogs von mit dabei bin oder so
und die danach ihre stimme gehören die
haben gesagt so wow wie klinge ich bin
eben das wirklich historisches bild
erkennt dass alle wir schicken diese
lachenden whatsapp smileys und hängen
eigentlich nur im bett und weinen halt
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich denk mal ganz kurz auf den
mittlerweile wieder für die playstation
gebunden haben er ist ein ruhiger also
gleich mal drauf verliebte gewinnern der
kommentar ist der 61 tausendstel
fischbacher du heißt auf instagram
katharina punkt mendes ich werde dir
dort eine direct message schreiben das
heißt bitte checkten instagram und dann
regeln wir alles wichtig die sachen zu
schenken ich hoffe du freust dich leute
wenn ihr diese nintendo 3ds xl gewinnen
können wie gesagt einfach main kanal
abonnieren und nikon tat schrecklich
erreichen kann
[Musik]